putin has made very clear all along  that uh their security and his mind  is what's at stake here and they do not  want i don't want to interrupt u.s and  nato also said ukraine is not a country  and he has been saying this going back  many many years so this has been these  territorial ambitions have existed  security component  they they have they go way back and they  they pre-exist i love what he says i  want to focus on the security component  right because that's the component  that's that's interesting to you she is  so unhinged that hannity has to say hey  tulsi that there's kind of like other  realities here that you're not living in  and i'm going to try to pull you back  towards them like hannity's saying  your pro-russian propaganda is a bit too  much  this is when a friend would be like  tulsi you might want to sit this one out  when hannity has to slow you down